[Music]
welcome and we are live go incognito
I'll or podcast Lord's a game without
net with the legendary sir
/ Lord Toby well versed in the round
deep silver and we what do we got here
we've got iron harvest the latest
endeavor going on from team service a
lot so we tell the people about iron
harvest what's going on with this game
so iron harvest is a RTS a real-time
strategy game well usually I do the RPGs
right but this time I have something
also very yes yes RTS or realtime
strategy game and iron harvest is
squad-based cover based RTS where you
have to take cover be smarter than your
opponent and what's the coolest of all
it's with giant mechs and everyone likes
mags we like Beck's and we like World
War 1 x diesel funk so there's a lot
going on here let's get right into this
game and sort of people what they're
missing
about iron harvest ok so here at PAX
hmmm we have this wonderful booth of
course yes the people can play one of
the challenge maps so iron harvest will
be or is mainly focused on the
single-player campaign so there will be
21 missions for 3 factions 7 each but of
course there's also different
challenges and skirmishes you can do and
what we can see here right now is I'm
playing as paulownia one of the three
factions against Saxony and we already
see a wonderful mixture of different max
and infantry units while the infantry
units are almost the same for each
faction they kind of differ in the
weaponry they have so the Polana units
can shoot a little bit further Poland
the sec city guys are a little bit
stronger the mechs extremely unique so
for example this big boy here is
something like a running walking bunker
so if I put in these boys here these
Cowboys and then there will double shoot
not only is this a mortar so he's okay
shooting in distance now it's pretty
close but they will also from the inside
shoot those minions here for instance so
what is extremely important in iron
harvest is that it's relatively similar
to a game called Company of Heroes so
it's called its cover base as you can
see here you have to move your units
behind cover to keep them alive nice I
love the cover says that is awesome
love and also the camera zooming in you
get a little bit more of that detail
than what in general we use this looks
fantastic that's the Unity engine so we
do everything to make it run smooth on
PC Xbox and Playstation nice and it will
be releasing in the 1st of September
this seems almost could be a
cross-generational
title with certain next generation
platforms I mean Never Say Never
for now we are aiming at doing the
single-player campaign of course but
also support this the
the multiplayer after released so we are
planning events afterwards or want to
have a ranking system and so on
don't overdo it it's the it's a well
it's a huge title so need to do small
steps but but once we are there I think
there is a huge amazing game waiting for
the people and I think it's really
pretty cool that's what you said about
the units like how all the infantry
units and things like that are very
similar but that different weaponry
now the weapons that look like they're
spinning can like your people go pick
them up and then you can use your
opposite faction does it change the
stats of the actual character that you
have or it's just a different weapons
your more attack or so on and so forth
that is an extreme clever question thank
you for that so the weapons spinning on
the ground every infantry units that
dies drops its weapon which means that
you can use your unit and change them on
the fly on the battlefield so we have
engineers here who are pretty weak and
shooting we can see the stats right not
very good but if we take those machine
guns here they will after some time
become machine gunners now this unit is
almost dead already so it's well not the
best to use them but still we change
them right now into machine gunners this
means you can on the fly on the
battlefield adapt the unit class and now
we have works with the mechs - no
unfortunately not you cannot change the
mag however now we have the big boy man
yeah big boy go ahead is a big boy and
when you shoot down a Mac like this one
here this or this you can either use it
as cover or you can dismantle it and use
the resources for your own of course
right so again it's a technical thing
now the cool thing about the max is not
only that they look kick-ass and that
they do kick it and yes they do
they also stump through everything they
come across so uneven terrain even
houses exactly let's let
right that let's see how boy coming big
boy and he welcome he will now let's say
we have units here inside yes
storm the building but big boy doesn't
care for any buildings this also shows
you that the entire map is destructible
nice not randomly what I mean is that
when we shoot this barrel here for
example the house should explode only
right where the bullet hit me if the
thing you're shooting at yes love that
destructibility now now is your aerial
combat also or is it just ground combat
at this point at this point we are only
talking about ground combat and will
most likely keep it like that but
against Never Say Never
yes the universe is eternal speaking of
the universe we talked before this
universe looks awesome
again it's diesel Parkinson now this is
based on someone legendary that is
creating this that Iron Horse is
actually influence can you tell people
with around a little bit about that yes
very clever question again you guys have
well prepared I love that so the artist
is called Yakubu zovsky is a Polish
artist who was known and now sorry Jakub
if I get the year wrong I think it was
2016 or 17 his artwork was trending the
outward you can see all over the booth
and if he was he's painting this rural
like landscape and in distance with the
max so these artworks he created were
trending on reddit then a company
approached them about doing a board game
maybe one of you might know it's called
scythe
and we approached and then or King art
games reproach them to actually do how
about we do an RTS about that so the the
board game is kind well it is it takes
place in the same universe but the
gameplay is different while in the Union
in the board game you're taking care of
you mostly of economics right here it's
really shooting destroy an RTS style now
look at that the German there also
section is also well prepared yes they
are they got a big boy himself yeah and
the big boy themselves see that now it's
like an open fire creating some smoke
here there's a stealth cover system as
well so you can hide your units and the
bushes and stuff that there's really
cried a lot of tactics and and strategy
you can do here can you show us the
where the resources are and we've had
that portion of that so right now we are
playing special packs build where we
don't have to take care of resources but
it's a clever question anyway because
you're not going to generate it you you
are generating resources over time and
to get general resources you need
capture points like this iron mine for
instance and over the you see that right
now we just got a lot of some iron where
over the time you are getting the
resources however the opponent can
capture it from you and you can slowly
bleed out of resources so what happens
in this game is that essentially the the
frontline of the battlefield is moving
back or forth the entire game the entire
match so that that's what the game is
about a moving frontline
so unlike an age of empires or c'mon
conquer something that you took your
eyes aren't on your base most of the
time where you build up in a corner to
district difference exactly but it's on
the battlefield because you have to keep
your your max you need to take care of
your max you don't want to lose them
there's an experience system so they get
better over time they lose you today
they win you they gain new moves so the
engineers can build new buildings for
example on
so you really have great interest in
keeping them alive do you have like a
class that's gonna like heal or repair
give them the max themselves so we have
the medics who of course taking care of
the infantry units the medics once they
level up they can build a field hospital
which is really good because let me show
you there's an interesting mechanic in
the game right it's called retreat so if
you well but but this time it's actually
good because break it up like in real
time it keeps you alive so if you if you
push the R button a unit will get a
small boost and hit points and speed
they will run back you cannot move them
anymore
but once they arrive back home you can
hear them completely okay so don't
automatically do that so you don't have
to have somebody to sign that's kind of
cool now if we arrive back at home we
push the R button again and see where
we're getting the units back again and
now we have full squatting this quarter
go back out now no initially we're
focusing on the single-player campaign
and I wonder before I get into most of
our questions but I wanted to ask how
are we telling the story here are we are
we gonna do stages which cinematic
that's kind of kind of convey the next
level of what's going on
I'm impressed about you how good you are
prepared at am so very good we have as I
said earlier we have 21 missions seven
missions for each faction action and we
record it over 60 minutes of fully
motion scenes
Wow so the storytelling is extremely
important nice lets me briefly tell
briefly tell you what it's about so
section II miss representing kinda
Germany and Russia is kinda Russia in in
this alternative universe and those two
are fighting on the ground of palana
kinda Poland so also world war y exam
when I got cheese alternative World War
one exactly going on here
and while the Polish people are more
well they feel repressed of course
because the battles are taking place on
their country and they're losing ground
and people and resource and so on so
what's happening is that the Polish
people are something like it's called
them guerrilla fighters sharpshooters
writing from from cover however
unfortunately they have rather cheap
units and are not very powerful but they
can mass produce fat so that's their big
I got the numbers that they got the
numbers section II for instance they
have extremely expensive units right but
they are very powerful and attack and
defense but you have to have the cash to
if you hear two incidents the balance in
that's balanced and Russia the rust
Russia yet yeah they are the strongest
faction in terms of attack but very bad
in defending even stronger than German
even stronger than Germany however they
are very bad at defending so when you
attack with reproduce it rather make
sure you could you finish your job they
hit back your defense ain't enough for
that yeah you don't want them to hit
back because then
yeah are you planning on having this
setup or for like flavors player or oh
yeah
for online or things like that exactly
it would be so fun I'm also looking
extremely forward to the to the
multiplayer because after release we
will have multiplayer sessions and
different events supporting the
multiplayer multiplayer confirm it's
coming you heard here the round four and
it will be supported after release with
different funds nice some some ranking
system and so on it would be pretty cool
I'm sure cool are you guys planning on
adding more factions and adding more
classes and all of that into the future
for now is focusing on through right now
that seems like an obvious idea right
but the DLC this could be something for
the future I'm sure
awesome Lord so V iron harvest looks
awesome thing I am not the traditional
RTS guy but new episode me but you can
start there's the bracelet port listen
but honestly the diesel from aspect all
the balancing in the game with the
different factions and the fact that you
said there's gonna be a strong story
beat is really exciting boats are
playing there's going to be a
multiplayer component yeah and I want to
see you guys I wanted to see the iron
law podcast do it you two versus two
which team is the best let's do that I'm
gonna see fights yeah we got we gotta
get out we gotta get a lot of weight
loss without doing that as well now Mike
white last question as far as how closer
we will to release and obviously formats
and things of that nature so this joke
unfortunately only works in Europe
because the game is called
1920 Plus right in iron how was 1920
plus and it's 1 9 21st of September 2020
in the US you do it the other way around
the first of September from now of a
year roughly and it releases a PC Xbox
and Playstation it will be a great
artist also for consoles also well we
care that way this is a lower podcast
approved Lord Toby a legend in design
Lord Rael alleged can outweigh our
harvest looks fantastic always a
pleasure but it's you every time brother
and you heard it here first Lords a game
with that day
[Music]